bonjour à tous je vous propose cet
après-midi de revoir les explications de
vote autour de la réforme du droit
d'asile
une réforme adoptée définitivement par
le parlement en juillet dernier en plein
drame des migrants et alors que françois
hollande annoncé hier que la france
accueillerait 24 mille réfugiés sur les
deux prochaines années
cette réforme vise à réduire le délai de
traitement d'un dossier et surtout à
améliorer les conditions d'accueil des
demandeurs
le but de la loi et de ramener de deux
ans à neuf mois en 2010 est le délai des
réponses grâce à une simplification des
procédures
autre objectif de la loi améliorer les
conditions d'accueil en permettant de
nouvelles places en centres d'accueil
la droite et l'extrême droite ont voté
contre le texte en jugeant qu'il allait
encourager des dizaines de milliers de
demandeurs supplémentaires
l'extrême gauche et les écologistes ont
jugé la réforme trop peu ambitieuse
sachez enfin qu'un débat sera organisé
au parlement sur cette question des
réfugiés mercredi 16 septembre
voilà tout de suite donc direction
l'hémicycle à monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues avant de passer au vote
je venais la parole à ceux de nos
collègues qui ont été inscrits pour
expliquer leur vote j'indique au sénat
que la conférence des présidents a fixé
à raison d'un orateur par groupe
à 7 minutes le temps attribué à chaque
groupe politique
les sénateurs ne figurant sur la liste
aucun groupe disposant eu deux trois
minutes
je vous inviterai ensuite à vous rendre
dans la salle des conférences pour voter
puis je suspendrai la séance pendant la
durée du scrutin prévu pour une demi
heure je proclamerai enfin le résultat
des six du dépouillement
autour de 15h 45 puis monsieur le
ministre je donnerai la parole au
gouvernement pour expliquer son vote la
parole et à jean claude requier pour le
groupe du rassemblement démocratique
social et européen
avez la parole
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues l'asie et
ses valeureux d'amener sont au coeur de
bien des discussions et débats
ici comme ailleurs en asie limite
personnes se trouvent et encore
récemment à dérive sur la mer abandonnés
par leurs passeurs qui semble repoussé
par m'bolhi hors de ses eaux
territoriales
le dilemme insoluble nationalité est un
facteur d'exclusion dirimant mais n'ont
pas totalement opérant entre ce qui peut
avoir les droits et les autres comme l'a
rappelé la proposition de bruxelles
d'instaurer des quotas de réfugiés la
problématique l'afflux massif de
réfugiés c'est nos rivages se posent à
l'échelle européenne ne nous attendons
pas pas sur ce qui est déjà connu
est ce la réalité telle que nous la
connaissons à lampedusa
wasquehal et le plan de la commission
européenne prévoit notamment des quotas
obligatoires pour assurer une estime
sûre et équitable les réfugiés en cas de
crise et donc d'affluence if inhabituel
et temporaires un transfert de l'énergie
l'entré temps de l'union européenne plus
de 300 à 2000 demandes d'asile ont été
traités en 2014 la moitié seulement ont
été acceptés et six pays les plus
attractifs ont assumé l'essentiel de
l'effort allemagne suède france italie
royaume-uni et pays-bas mais ne
paraissait pas ne pas un bon pas à la
politique arrêt de migratoire commune la
grande bretagne l'irlande et le danemark
ne sait pas par exemple concernés par
cette obligation
le groupe indien se comprennait
république a fait connaître son
opposition par principe à l'instauration
de tels quotas
particulièrement en matière d'asile il
monsieur le musée intérieur vous allez
ici même jeudi dernier rassuré sur ce
point tout en précisant les cartes et la
position de la france sur le plan de la
commission européenne alors pour ce qui
est de l'échelle rond national
nous considérons que la rationalisation
mises en oeuvre par le projet de loi
initial est souhaitable et nous
souhaitons nous avons donc de l'esprit
de la réforme initiée en matière d'asile
comment armes d'autres matières la
france n'a cessé d'osciller
entre l'amour des grandes idées et la
réalité très empirique de petits
arrangements pas tant à travers la soupe
dit budgétisation constante de la
mission immigration asile et intégration
ce projet de loi tente de concilier deux
objectifs pourtant difficilement
réconciliable l'inconditionnalité de
l'accueil et le bon traitement des
demandeurs d'asile la france représente
en valeur près de 75 me demande soit 15
% de l'ensemble des demandes au niveau
européen nous soyons ici
d'une part c'est un temps d'avancé
particules significative en matière de
garanties octroyées aux demandeurs
d'asile
conformément aux directives européennes
leur examen des demandes formulées
auprès de l'ofpra comme la cnd à
l'établissement analystes les pays sur
le droit au maintien sur le territoire
de tous et de leurs bases ils la tenue
d'entretiens personnel la présence d'un
avocat lors de ces entretiens la prise
en compte systématique de la
vulnérabilité des demandeurs la
possibilité huit clos pour les audiences
devant la cour la possibilité d'utiliser
la vidéoconférence pour entretien
conduit parfois qui a été ajoutée donc
par le sénat ancien public nous soyons
notre part les avancées faites pour
réformer un système d'asile à bout de
souffle notamment en matière de
reddition et l'inscription dans la loi
des délais d'instruction trois mois pas
pour sûr normal 96 heures lorsque le
demandeur est passé en détention en 2014
le froid a recruté serait de dire aux
gens ce qui a permis de réduire les
délais
nous attendons les résultats de
l'expérimentation voté par le sénat qui
permettra la déconcentration de l'ofpra
par la création d'antennes locales dans
certains départements les difficultés
étaient nombreuses et réelles nous
savons du fait notamment de la
centralisation parisienne de l'office
toutefois notre collègue pierre yvon
combot la colombe à arette eu l'occasion
de signaler lors de la discussion
générale
là certaines des solutions trouvées en
commission et en sciences furic ne nous
paraissent pas conformes aux engagements
internationaux de la france
texte procédurales traitant de la
gestion administrative du droit d'asile
le présent projet de loi quant à lui de
pas moins que les vraies questions
politiques celle de la gestion des flux
migratoires à l'échelle européenne ou
encore celle de l'impossibilité de faire
exécuter les obligations de quitter le
territoire français
que faire une fois le demandeur d'asile
définitivement débouté
celui ci vient grossir les rangs mais ça
me va bien tout comme sa famille alors
même que le texte prévoit par exemple un
accès au marché du travail
lorsque d'une décision n'a été prononcée
dans un délai de neuf mois
le texte n'a pas trouvé de solution même
s'il est vrai que ces solutions sont
talent du politique et administrative le
sénat a ainsi voté le principe selon
lequel la décision définitive du rejet
de la demande vos obligations de quitter
le territoire français
la mise en oeuvre d'une telle solution
n'est pas sans poser des questions de
conformité au regard du principe
international de droit à une vie
familiale puisque les trajets déboutés
ne pourra donc pas b2 pourra donc
bénéficier d'un titre de séjour pour
réunification familiale au pour état de
santé sans parler des difficultés
administratives toujours très concrète
milles à l'heure au parlement rapport de
la cour des comptes a commencé par le
devenir des procédures parallèles
ces dispositions posent un réel problème
soulevé par directeur froid tantôt plan
juridique car raison du changement de la
nature de la mission des officiers de
protection que cela à zemmouri les
constats sont évidemment sont évidents
les solutions beaucoup moins et on en a
malheureusement tendance à être le plus
souvent purement incantatoire
pour toutes ces raisons et même si à
l'unité le sénat a accepté le changement
de nom de la procédure donne de cette
ppl d'équinoxe appelle ça plaît dans la
réforme de l'asie là on a mis réforme du
droit d'asile
la loi voit donc on n'avait retrouvé que
réforme que l'asie est 16e tir sera plus
un peu les amis de katherine venir donc
passé que réforme l'arrivée c'est mieux
pour toutes ces raisons et malgré cette
semaine le titre
le groupe rdse de vin sont unanimes
s'abstiendra ce texte soumis à notre
hauteur merci mon cher collègue
la parole est maintenant monsieur
stéphane ravier bon
les sénateurs appartenant à aucun gros
noms inscrits pour 3 minutes
vous avez la parole
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues beaucoup a
déjà été dit sur cette loi et je crois
avoir moi même exprimé ma position avec
quelques clarté dans cet hémicycle mon
vote ne sera donc pas une surprise
je souhaite donc simplement revenir sur
le principal changement apporté par le
sénat à ce projet je parle bien
évidemment de cet amendement apporté à
l'article 14 afin de prévoir que la
décision définitive de rejet prononcé
par l'office français de protection des
réfugiés et apatrides
l'offre a après un appel éventuel devant
la commission nationale du droit d'asile
vos obligations de quitter le territoire
français
cet amendement reflète bien l'incapacité
de l'ump à proposer une véritable
alternative à ce gouvernement
certes c'est un a manqué un amendement
qui va dans le bon sens mais pour l'ump
cela relève de la posture il est clair
que l'on aime à jouer les braves
quand on est dans l'opposition pour
tenter donner de donner le change à ses
électeurs en particulier aux français en
général tant de fois trahi
mais au delà des arguties juridiques
demeure la question principale celle de
l'exécution effective de cette fameuse
obligation de quitter le territoire tant
que 90 ou 95% des déboutés pour en 2
facto se maintenir en france
la belle notion d'asile continuera
d'être dénaturée pour rester un appel
d'air permanent pour l'immigration
clandestine
monsieur le ministre vous vous êtes dit
attaché à ce que les déboutés du droit
d'asile quitte effectivement le pays
mais le maintien de temps de clandestins
sur notre sol ce scandaleux état de fait
sur lequel prospère toutes sortes de
profiteurs de la misère
tout cela doit beaucoup aux consignes
que vous-même donnée au préfet monsieur
le ministre pourra venir à cet
amendement il est également permis de
rappeler la profonde incohérences qui
mine la crédibilité politique de ce
qu'il est convenu d'appeler la droite
plurielle notamment sur l'asile
l'immigration et tous les grands sujets
de société
en effet comme on l'a vu avec la
position de notre collègue madame létard
qui a critiqué cet amendement aussi
timide soit il cet attelage à droite
comprend une aile centriste qui est
essentiellement aligné sur la gauche
j'ai évoqué madame létard mais en dehors
de cette assemblée je pourrais parler de
monsieur juppé ou de madame kosciusko
morizet depuis des décennies maintenant
ce courant empêcher toute réforme
sérieuse lorsque l'ump où ses
prédécesseurs étaient au pouvoir
ce n'est donc pas l'ump qui va y changer
quelque chose car je veux rappeler une
fois encore que nous ne faisons que
transposer des textes européens que vos
partis respectifs ont déjà adoptées à ce
même échelon
si seulement les obligations de quitter
le territoire était aussi bien exécuté
que vous exécutez ici mes chers
collègues les ordres de bruxelles pour
changer vraiment les choses en france il
faut rentrer avec certaines logiques
avec certaines postures avec certains
faux semblant d'opposition
cessons de nous soumettre à ce qui nous
aide à ceux qui nous imposent comment
accueillir toujours plus de réfugiés et
qui bientôt vont nous imposer des quotas
d'immigrants plus ou moins légaux de
pays à pays
réveillons-nous avant qu'il ne soit trop
tard et faisons enfin des lois pour ce
qu'ils nous confient leurs suffrages
c'est à dire pour les français d'abord
les paroles les tables à mme catherine
tremblay avec madame valérie létard
pardonnez moi c'est sans doute parce que
elle avait été cité excuse moi mes chers
collègues merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre messieurs les
rapporteurs mes chers collègues après
les leçons données nous allons essayer
en tout cas de passer je l'espère
quelques instants à parler juste et tout
simplement d'un texte de loi dont
l'objectif c'est qu'il soit applicable
et qu'il serve l'intérêt général et non
des postures politiques monsieur ravier
nous voici donc
parce que si vous accuser les autres
regardez-vous cinq minutes
qu'est-ce que vous avez de concret à
proposer si ce n'est des solutions
inapplicable alors nouveau si donc nous
voici donc parvenus à la fin de l'examen
du projet de loi relatif à la réforme de
l'asile permettez-moi d'abord de saluer
la qualité de notre débat malgré la
pression de l'actualité liée au drame
humanitaire au medicare année nous avons
garder présent à l'esprit notre objectif
rendre au droit de l'asile son unique
vocation qui est d'accueillir dans de
bonnes conditions les personnes qui en
ont besoin de la protection de la france
de le faire au mieux et de traiter en
même temps humainement mais fermement
tous ceux qui ont tenté le tout pour le
tout en déposant une demande d'asile
alors même que leur demande
d'immigration ne relevez quelquefois pas
de ce droit
permettez moi de saluer à nouveau la
qualité du travail de rapporteur de la
commission des lois
même si nous avons eu un point fort de
divergence je me félicite des nombreuses
clarifications et des très utile
avancées qui ont sensiblement amélioré
le texte qui nous avaient été transmis
par l'assemblée nationale monsieur le
rapporteur
je voudrais saluer également la qualité
d'écouté et d'ouverture quand vous avez
fait preuve monsieur le ministre
alors comme je vous l'avais suggéré au
cours de la discussion générale jusqu'à
reprendre mon amendement mort né sur la
territorialisation de l'ofpra je pense
que nous avons fait oeuvre utile et
j'espère vivement que la meute
commission mixte paritaire qui se
réunira prochainement permettra de
déboucher sur un texte commun comme nous
avons été unanimes à le dire cette
réforme est une première étape
essentielle dans la construction d'une
politique d'ensemble cohérente de
l'accueil des étrangers dans notre pays
je voudrais également me réjouir du fait
que le travail de concertation que nous
avions entrepris avec mon collègue jean
louis touraine en 2013 et qui a débouché
sur un rapport sur la réforme de l'asile
présenté au ministre de l'intérieur en
novembre 2013 et large urnes ans nourrit
les différentes mesures de ce projet de
loi
il me semble que l'objectif de
raccourcissement des délais a été tenue
comme je lé eu comme j'ai eu l'occasion
de
dire au cours de nos débats cet objectif
doit d'abord se lire en positif notre
réforme aura atteint son but lorsque la
procédure accélérée permettra d'accorder
très rapidement l'asile à ceux qui en
ont besoin à ce niveau l'absence de
conditions préalables de domiciliation
inscrite dans le texte
grâce à notre amendement l'obtention
d'une carte de séjour sans délai une
fois la protection accordée voté
également à notre initiative la
possibilité d'entamer immédiatement une
procédure de réunification familiale
adopté par la commission des lois sont
autant de signes de notre volonté
d'intégrer mieux et très vite les
réfugiés les bénéficiaires d'une
protection
je me félicite également que nos débats
mais permis d'introduire dans le texte
du sénat des propositions du rapport qui
nous semblait essentiel pour assurer un
traitement équilibré des demandes
d'asile je veux parler tout d'abord de
la question des dégoûtés qui me
paraissait difficile de passer sous
silence ou de renvoyer à un texte sur
l'immigration irrégulière en effet une
personnes déboutées du droit d'asile
n'est pas dans la même situation qu un
étranger en situation irrégulière car
nous la connaissons nous avons traité sa
demande et nous savons bien que de la
renvoyer à la clandestinité ne règle
rien c'est la raison pour laquelle je me
félicite que la commission des lois est
accepté d'adopter un amendement
proposant la possibilité de mettre en
place des centres dédiés aux débouté en
ajoutant au texte un article 14 bis il
s'agit pour moi d'une avancée
considérable et sa mise en oeuvre à
titre expérimental dans un premier temps
qui devrait être lancée très rapidement
nous donnera l'occasion je l'espère de
mieux accompagner vers leur tour les
personnes déboutées du droit d'asile et
ceux vers leur pays d'origine
à chaque fois que se justifiera d'autres
propositions importantes issues de notre
rapport sur l'asile ont trouvé leur
place au sénat je pense en particulier
comme je lui ai rappelé tout à l'heure à
l'expérimentation de la
territorialisation de l'ofpra avoir
adopté un schéma d'orientation
directives des demandeurs d'asile
associé à la création de futures grandes
régions conduit logiquement à se poser
la question d'une organisation des
concentrés de l'ofpra
celle ci devra se faire progressivement
afin de tenir compte des efforts
importants demandés par la mise en place
la réforme en cours est le corollaire de
cette déconcentration à venir c'est bien
évidemment la possibilité pour la cour
nationale du droit d'asile ne se rendre
elle aussi sur les territoires notre
amendement sur l'émission foraine adopté
à l'article 10 le permettra permettez
moi également de me réjouir que notre
débat en séance publique est permis de
réintroduire dans le texte
les critères d'évaluation de la
vulnérabilité je n'ignore pas la
position de la commission des lois qui
estime que le rappel de l'article de la
directive est suffisante
mais mon sentiment est que parfois une
piqûre de rappel n'est pas inutile et au
quotidien tout le monde n'aura pas
forcément le texte de la directive sous
les yeux enfin à notre initiative
également le sénat a réintroduit d'une
manière plus opérationnelle que par le
biais de la ct ap la consultation des
collectivités compétentes en matière
d'habitat dans l'élaboration des schémas
régionaux qui viendront décliner le
schéma national d'hébergement des
demandeurs
ce point n'est pas négligeable si nous
voulons assurer une meilleure
répartition de l'accueil entre les
territoires et permettre une meilleure
acceptabilité sociale des centres
d'hébergement par la population d'une
commune
le bilan de nos débats et donc en ce qui
me concerne largement positif avec
évidemment un seul regret il s'agit du
débat que nous avons eu autour de
l'introduction à l'article 14 de la
linea 17
précisons qu'une décision de l'ofpra et
de la cour nationale du droit d'asile
pourraient valoir obligation de quitter
le territoire français
je reste convaincu que cette mesure si
elle devait être adoptée définitivement
serait dommageable en termes
d'efficacité comme en termes de délais
et non par posture tout simplement parce
que ça ne serait pas fonctionnel néons 1
j'ai accepté de retirer notre amendement
de suppression contre l'engagement du
président de la commission des lois de
revoir ce dispositif en lien avec les
propositions qui avaient été faites par
monsieur le ministre sur les occulter f
et avec l'assemblée nationale et je
compte bien sûr monsieur le président de
la commission sur votre volonté de
parvenir à une solution acceptable par
tous c'est donc dans ces conditions et
avec cette réserve que le groupe udi
adoptera le texte du projet de loi
portant réforme de l'asie
tel qu amendé par notre haute assemblée
car je voudrais leur dire pour conclure
l'urgence c'est bien de sauver notre
droit d'asile en évitant que la
procédure ne soit détournée de son objet
etc ainsi rénové elles nous permettent
d'accueillir plus rapidement les
personnes qui reçoivent la protection de
la france
rendre notre dispositif plus souple plus
proche des territoires plus opérants
tout en réduisant les délais excessifs
qui nuisent à sa lisibilité
c'est certainement la meilleure manière
de réussir la réforme de l'asile et ceci
ne constitue qu'une partie d'une
politique globale de l'accueil des
migrants jeu conclut monsieur le
président de keefe qui frappent aux
portes de l'europe
le débat sur les quotas les navires
mobilisés en méditerranée le
renforcement du régime frontex la
politique de co-développement avec les
pays d'origine et de départ de centaines
de milliers de migrants massés sur les
côtes libyennes sont autant de questions
que nous devons traiter au niveau
européen
à côté d'une nécessaire politique
européenne de l'asile
c'est bien ce défi de la prison compte
solidaire de l'immigration de la
pauvreté entre nos pays qui est posée
plutôt que de naître la faire que de
quelques-uns
cela demande des réponses urgentes et
équitable je vous remercie
merci mon cher collègue
la parole cette fois ci c'est le bon
moment et à notre collègue catherine
granger
l'enquêtrice vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président ce président
monsieur le rapporteur
mais sur les rapporteurs pardon monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues
permettez moi juste une petite accroche
à l'attention de monsieur raviser je
voulais simplement lui dire que nous
sommes tous des législateurs responsable
éclairé traiter du sujet de l'asile qui
est un sujet d'une grande gravité ne
relève pas d'une posture politique
nous nous l'avons compris vous je n'en
suis pas sûr mes chers collègues alors
que la triste actualité relate jour
après jour le désarroi de ces milliers
de migrants qui tentent de franchir les
frontières européennes pour y chercher
refuge
notre pays la france a le devoir
avec ses partenaires européens de
trouver des solutions humanitaire parmi
ces solutions bien évidemment se trouve
la politique d'asile
cette démarche s'inscrit dans un
processus historique qui remonte au
moyen âge
lorsqu'un persécutés pouvait se réfugier
dans un monastère où un couvent en vertu
de la tradition d impunité
il faudra attendre la révolution
française pour que la france offre
l'asile aux personnes persécutées en
raison de leur combat pour la liberté
ainsi héritage de la protection des
persécutés le droit d'asile est inscrit
dans le préambule de la constitution de
1946 depuis lors la france a toujours su
offrir sa protection opprimés et aux
victimes des régimes bafouant les droits
de l'homme
force est de constater que la procédure
d'asile aujourd'hui à bout de souffle ne
répond plus aux véritables enjeux de
l'asile sa vocation été dévoyé et elle a
été transformée en véritable machine à
légaliser des clandestins il est
nécessaire et urgent d'entreprendre
cette réforme de la de l'île afin de
donner du sens au droit d'asile pour
mettre fin au détournement et aux
dérives des procédures
il faut prioriser toutes les attentes
sur les personnes venant de pays à hauts
risques comme c'est le cas aujourd'hui
apporter une réponse de dignité pour ces
personnes qui sont en souffrance est
dans une grande détresse et répondre
rapidement aux autres par une reconduite
hors des frontières pour bénéficier de
l'asile en france
il faut apporter les preuves des
persécutions que les conditions de vie
sont inhumaines dans le pays d'origine
en effet mes chers collègues il ne faut
pas confondre l'immigration politique
avec l'immigration économique
ce fut d'ailleurs le préalable de
l'excellent rapport de nos rapporteur
monsieur françois noël buffet et
monsieur roger karoutchi
c'est pourquoi nos exigences doivent
être maximale est optimale car
l'objectif de pouvoir accorder
rapidement l'asile à ceux qui en ont
besoin
la difficulté qui est la nôtre
aujourd'hui dans notre droit est dans la
situation de fait
tiens à la procédure qui a été dévoyé
si le texte du gouvernement cherche sans
véritable efficacité accélérer les
procédures
ils n'apportent néanmois aucune solution
tant dans un meilleur contrôle des
entrées sur le territoire et ne propose
ni mesure ni moyens pour procéder
rapidement à la reconduite à la
frontière de tous les débuts débouté ce
qui a été récemment mis en lumière par
la cour des comptes à la pluie de
chiffres connus de tous en effet la
france compte chaque année environ 40000
débouté 75 % des demandes d'asile sont
rejetés annuellement en moyenne
or ces déboutés ne sont quasiment pas
renvoyés dans leur pays d'origine et sur
la base de ce constat nous devons en
convenir tous notre système présente en
caractère attractif
le simple fait de solliciter l'asile
et qui vaut pour les demandeurs à
l'obtention à moyen terme d'un titre de
séjour
voilà pourquoi le nombre de demandeurs
ne cesse d'augmenter
par conséquent notre groupe se satisfait
des travaux du sénat qui ont permis
d'améliorer ce texte par l'introduction
de deux principes importants à nos yeux
celui de l'insertion des bénéficiaires
d'une protection et celui de
l'éloignement des personnes des buts
déboutés de leur demande d'asile
pour ce faire nous avons réduit les
délais de traitement des dossiers et les
avons inscrit dans la loi les décisions
ofpra dans les trois mois au lieu de six
mois actuellement pour une procédure
normale et quinze jours en procédure
accélérée 96 heures en rétention
nous avons appliqué en matière d'asile
et de droit de séjour
l'adage froces omnia corocoro pitt toute
fraude entraîne le rejet systématique de
la demande d'asile
nous avons permis c'est le latin qui
vous pertes sur mes chers collègues
pourtant l'enseignement du latin et du
grec est primordial nous avons permis de
rendre immédiatement les obligations de
quitter le territoire pour les débouter
le rejet de la demande d'asile ou
obligation de quitter le territoire
nous avons appliqué strictement la
directive européenne retour en réduisant
de 30 à 7 jours le délai de départ
volontaire qui est fixé à l'étranger à
l'égard duquel une obligation de quitter
le territoire a été fixé et nous n'avons
pas autorisée a débouté a engagé une
autre procédure pour bénéficier d'un
titre de séjour
également nous avons abordé le born et
le concept de l'inconditionnalité de
l'accueil dans les hébergements
d'urgence à la jurisprudence du conseil
d'état tout dépent août déboutés ne peut
plus bénéficier de l'hébergement
auxquels ils avaient droit durant la
procédure
enfin nous avons décidé
l'expérimentation d'une déconcentration
de l'ofpra par la création d'antennes
permanente dans les départements qui
sont confrontés à un fort afflux de
demandeurs d'asile ainsi que la mise en
place des audiences foraines pour la
semaine des as
notre préoccupation qui est celle de
beaucoup de français est d'arriver à
donner une situation humainement
acceptable à des migrants fuyant leur
pays à cause des guerres des crimes
arbitraire perpétuer et des
discriminations violente
je souhaiterais remercier vivement on
nous dit au nom du groupe
mais notre rapporteur ces français
françois noël buffet mais c'est roger
karoutchi notre rapporteur pour avis
alors pour leur excellent travail leur
écoute et leur détermination à rendre ce
texte efficace et respectueux de la
dignité humaine
le groupe ump votera pour ce texte
merci merci mes chers collègues
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
jean yves le conte pour le groupe
socialiste
vous avez la parole monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues je vais tout d'abord vous dire
la fierté que j'ai eus d'être le chef de
file du groupe socialiste sur ce texte
mais aussi celui de travailler sur un
texte du gouvernement issus de
l'assemblée nationale qui apportait
beaucoup de progrès pour notre droit
d'asile d'abord des méthodes pour
réduire les délais ensuite une
affirmation que le renforcement des
droits du demandeur d'asile avec un
tiers présent à l'entretien un recours
suspensif permettrait aussi d'améliorer
les délais enfin l'organisation de
l'accueil sur l'ensemble de notre
territoire c'est ses progrès ces
avancées nous devons constater à la
lecture du texte tel qu'il sort de la
lecture du sénat qu elles sont
maintenues et je voudrais m'en félicite
et je peux ajouter aussi que comme cela
a été dit par plusieurs de nos collègues
que grâce à notre rapporteur aval
élévateurs à l'ensemble des groupes
un certain nombre d'avancées ont pu être
enregistrées dans ce don au cours de ces
discussions
un certain nombre d'améliorations des
garanties une modification du conseil de
la composition du conseil
d'administration de l'ofpra la
possibilité de déconcentrer les services
de l'ofpra là où c'est nécessaire ou
mettre dans la loi la possibilité
d'audiences foraines de la cnd a enfin
l'amélioration à l'initiative du
rapporteur de la conjugaison entre d'une
part l'exigence de secret des sources
dans des cas très sensible avec d'autre
part l'exigence de du principe de
contradictoire
lors des audiences à la cnd a enfin une
amélioration une rapidité pour les
réunifications familiales mais toutefois
ces avancées ne doivent pas caché
l'inquiétude que nous avons à la sortie
et au moment de nous présenter sur le
vote final
compte tenu de la position de la
majorité sénatoriale sur l'eau que tf
automatique
le rapporteur parlait de messages
envoyés
la loi ce n'est pas un message la loi ce
n'est pas un communiqué de presse
loi et doit être efficace et elle doit
être opérationnelle et c'est la raison
pour laquelle il n'est pas possible de
souscrire à ce que vous avez proposé
pour des raisons de droits pour des
raisons d'efficacité mais aussi parce
que vous laissez supposer que finalement
sur cette question de serions laxiste
alors que si je vous invite je vous
invite à regarder le nombre de déboutés
du droit d'asile en france en allemagne
et à regarder le nombre de reconduites à
la frontière pour ne dire ou quel est le
pays qui a le plus de difficultés
sachant que parfait et c'est toujours
difficile et que de ce point de vue là
la meilleure manière de répondre à la
question des déboutés du droit d'asile
c'est le faire en sorte de ne plus
accepter ce qui était la norme jusqu'en
2012 c'est plus de deux ans pour une
demande d'asile est de faire en sorte
que grâce à ce projet nous arrivions au
maximum à 8 mois et au mieux à trois
mois parce que les garanties aurait été
donnée aux demandeurs d'asile si bien
que finalement leur demande si elles
sont légitimes seront reconnus au bout
de trois mois
et c'est plus facile à ce moment-là de
demander aux demandeurs de repartir
après trois mois ou après huit mois
qu'après deux ans et c'est là le coeur
du problème c'est pas de faire d occuper
automatique qui ne fonctionne pas parce
qu'il faut rajouter des procédures aux
procédures l'autre recul c'est sur le
droit du travail qui fait que le texte
qui est issu du sénat finalement ne sera
pas conforme au droit européen aux
exigences de la directive qui dit
qu'après une fois les demandeurs d'asile
doivent pouvoir être d'un fou avoir
accès au marché du travail
moi je vous le dit lorsqu'on quitte son
lieu de vie parce que la sécurité n'est
pas respectée que finalement on a plus
que sa tête ses bras et ses pieds
finalement la meilleure chose qu'on peut
donner c'est de donner son travail au
pays qui vous accueille et refuser
refuser ce droit
après neuf mois c'est finalement ne pas
se préparer tout à fait à accueillir les
demandeurs d'asile enfin à cette étape
et parce que je sais que dans la rue il
y a les avocats qui travaillent à la cda
qui manifestent je voudrais leur dire
que bien entendu
nous avons entendu leurs préoccupations
par rapport au juge unique mais ça
existe déjà dans beaucoup de pays et les
ordonnances de la cnd a sont aussi
finalement un juge unique sans
contradictoires le juge l'a maintenant
sera en contradictoires nous avons
entendu leurs préoccupations sur les
procédures accélérées
mais nous constatons aussi qu'il ya un
certain nombre de mesures qui sont
prises dans le texte pour permettre à la
cda de revenir aux procédures normales
si elle estime nécessaire
enfin bien entendu nous serons vigilants
sur ces questions mais nous considérons
que l'amélioration des délais que le
texte permet répond aux exigences du
droit
je voudrais aussi remercier au delà des
agents de l'état des agents de l'ofpra
des rapporteurs de la cnd à tous les
avocats les juges de l'asile la cimade
et associations d'accueil de terrain et
ceux qui font des permanences juridiques
grs la fnath qui tu as été mobilisés sur
ce texte
mais qui plus encore sont mobilisés au
jour le jour pour l'accueil des
demandeurs d'asile qui est qui témoigne
que finalement l'asie en france c'est
pas une question de l'état face aux
demandeurs mais c'est une question de la
france qui dans son ensemble est
mobilisé par les associations sur le
terrain pour marquer son attachement à
ce droit d'asile et le faire vivre au
quotidien et sur l'ensemble du
territoire
enfin en conclusion de cette réforme
donc contenu de de ce que j'ai dit sur
le droit du travail et sur l'octuplé f
automatique
le groupe socialiste ne pourra pas
apporter ses voix à la majorité
sénatoriale et pour tenu des avancées
qui ont été initialement dans le texte
et reste contenu aussi des avancées qui
ont été enregistrés au sénat nous nous
abstiendrons en espérant que nous
pourrons arriver lors de la cmp à faire
en sorte que la voix du sénat les
réelles avancées qui ont pu être
enregistrées que tous les bancs
aujourd'hui on signalait pourront être
écoutés et que la cmp se fera dans un
esprit constructif et c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous nous abstiendrons
nous nous abstiendrons pour que la
france
nous nous abstiendrons parce qu'il ya
des choses qui sont inacceptables dans
ce texte je les dis il y à l'hercules
nous voulons un texte qui soit conforme
au droit européen mais en même temps
nous souhaitons que le travail qui a été
fait au sénat et qui a beaucoup
d'aspects positifs puis est ce puisse
être pris en compte dans le texte final
et nous souhaitons donc que en sorte que
la cmp aboutisse enfin je voudrais de ce
point de vue dire que ce texte permettra
à la france d'être en accord avec le
droit européen et d'être debout face aux
enjeux que nous vivons aujourd'hui au
sud et à l'est de notre continent
60 % des demandeurs dans quatre pays
mais 14 % des demandeurs seulement dans
les pays qui sont à la frontière avec le
sud de la méditerranée cela montre que
double 1 ne fonctionne pas mais que
trouve que dublin ne fonctionne pas et
qu'ils puissent être réformé il faut que
la france soit en accord avec les textes
ce sera le cas une fois que le texte
sera voté
c'est la raison pour laquelle il nous
semble utile il faut qu'on de voter le
plus vite possible ce texte
mais après avoir une cmp après après que
la cmp et corriger les errements et les
communiqués de presse que vous auriez
vous qu'être que vous avez vous lu
aujourd'hui inscrire encore d'euros
conclure mon cher collègue c'est la
raison pour laquelle c'est la raison
pour laquelle parce que c'est important
vous savez le droit d'asile le droit
d'asile c'est le droit d'avoir des
droits c'est hannah arendt qui le disait
le droit pour chaque individu à
appartenir à l'humanité qui devrait être
garanti par l'humanité elle même et j'ai
la conviction
j'ai la conviction que si nous arrivons
grâce à cette abstention à un vote
favorable qui permette à la france de
porter cette part d'humanité nous aurons
faisons rutile je vous remercie
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
esther benbassa pour le groupe
écologiste
c'est le président de la parole monsieur
le président monsieur le ministre
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois
messieurs les rapporteurs mes chers
collègues
permettez moi pour commencer une cool
digressions une digression seulement en
apparence
en fait la france après plus de dix ans
de présence à retirer ses troupes
d'afghanistan
la question du sort réservé aux
personnes au personnel civil de
recrutement local interprète cuisiniers
jardiniers etc qui ont travaillé aux
côtés de nos forces est inévitablement
poser ces personnes sont menacées de
représailles pour avoir collaboré avec
l'ennemi
elles sont encore 800 plus la famille a
espéré que la france ne leur tournera
pas le dos monsieur les ministres des
affaires étrangères s'est récemment
engagé à ce que les demandes de visas
soit examiné avant l'été et que les
refus puissent être examinés l'été c'est
dans moins d'un mois
cet appel lancé je le deviens hôtesses
dont nous débattons lors de la
discussion générale du 7 mai dernier je
terminais mon propos en disant que si
les modifications suggérées par la
majorité sénatoriale venait à être
adopté ce projet de loi loin de mieux
garantir les droits et libertés
fondamentaux des demandeurs d'asile
tournerait au bouclier sécuritaire
sacrifiant les plus fragiles a une
obsession anti immigration jeu concluant
par ces mots nous écologistes
n'apporteront nos voix qu'un test
humaniste ambitieux et fidèle aux
valeurs de la france malheureusement
après près de quinze heures de débats et
plus de 250 exact amendements examinés
ce qui gèle qui contenait au départ
certaines dispositions susceptibles
d'améliorer la situation des demandeurs
d'asile a clairement changé de visée
elle répond encore moins aux
réajustements demandé par la législation
européenne en la matière la teneur de
nos débats m'a souvent surprise var ont
été les moments où les parlementaires
présents ont paru capables de tenir la
distance chiffres pourcentages et sigles
barbares pour se souvenir que nous
parlions d'êtres humains en souffrance
d'hommes de femmes d'enfants rare dans
les moments où nous avons su les
gratifier de l'autre gars que celui
évoqué autrefois par l'écrivain orgueil
scène clown des estivants de bayonne
voyant débarquer les réfugiés rouge
espagnol derrière des barrages de
gendarmes
mais françois sûr on l'a dit mieux que
moi dans le monde ceux qui jugent les
réfugiés comme ceux qui les défendent
n'ont aucune expérience personnelle de
la guerre de la révolution de
l'engagement au péril de sa vie de
l'exil forcé les réfugiés et ceux qui
traitent leurs demandes sont sur deux
planètes différentes
j'ose encore espérer que ce n'est pas
tout à fait vrai le groupe écologie
écologistes avaient espéré que les
débats se focaliserait sur l'asile qu'il
ne serait pas détournés pour servir de
basses fins politiciennes pour parler
politique migratoire clandestin un flux
de migrants il n'est guère étonnant
à cet égard que les articles relatif à
l'éloignement des personnes s'étant vu
définitivement refusé l'asile et
susciter les discussions les plus
longues et les plus âpres le teil soumis
à notre vote prévoit notamment des
amendements inacceptable en ces temps où
de milliers de personnes à la recherche
d'un asile périssent en mer
d'une part que la décision définitive de
rejet prononcé par l'eau fera le cas
échéant après que la scène des as et
statuer dans le même sens vaï obligation
de quitter le territoire français ce qui
vaut au cutter d'autre part que
l'étranger débouté de sa demande d'asile
ne puisse solliciter un titre de séjour
à noter enfin que l'administration
puisse à signer a réduit à résidence les
déboutés dans des centres dédiés en vue
de préparer leur éloignement
voilà qui n'honorait pas la france et
concernant ce dernier point je n'oublie
pas qu'en tant mois les dizaines de
milliers de réfugiés républicains
espagnols
le groupe est en 1939 dans des camps
comme celui d'argelès sur mer
je n'oublie pas non plus que le
gouvernement français aux à leur
proposer de retourner dans l'espagne
franquiste
ni qu'ils furent des portes à mathausen
dès 1940 par la wehrmacht
vous me direz que le contexte n'était
pas le même
certes mais qui nous dit que l'autre
contexte ne changera pas demain le
groupe écologiste ne pourra donc en
conscience a porté ses voix à ce texte
je vous la merci merci mes chers
collègues
la parole est maintenant à madame la
présidente eliane à ceux ci pour le
groupe communiste républicain et citoyen
la parole madame la présidente
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues 1770
c'est le nombre de personnes mortes ou
disparues en mer méditerranée depuis le
début de l'année selon l'organisation
internationale pour les migrations
soit un mort toutes les deux heures en
moyenne
qui sont ces migrants pourquoi ont-ils
quitté leur pays
voilà la première question que tout le
monde devrait se poser avant de
s'interroger sur leur arrivée pourquoi
parce qu'il de leur pays pour fuir la
misère la guerre et bientôt mes chers
collègues peut-être le dérèglement
climatique
en amont des textes tels que celui qui
nous est soumis nous devrions monsieur
le ministre nous poser collectivement
les questions de fond quel nouvel ordre
international avec une onu une eau à nu
refonder à bout nous a proposé quelle
politique de développement économique
digne de ce nom pouvons-nous adopté le
but de la commission européenne est
d'abord de stopper les flux migratoires
en direction de l'europe pas dans
d'éteindre les causes
avec l'opération triton confié à frontex
la priorité n'est pas de sauver les
migrants mais bien de surveiller les
frontières de l'union européenne
si françois hollande a fait un distinguo
net très nette entre migrants
économiques et demandeurs d'asile
il a aussi précisé qu'il était favorable
à une meilleure répartition de ces
derniers entre pays européens
mais comment mieux répartir des migrants
sans établir de quotas ou fixer des
seuils de dossiers de demandeurs d'asile
c'est avec cette contradiction car c'en
est une que ce débat sur ce débat que le
gouvernement que ce débat pardon le
gouvernement depuis une semaine
à matignon on évoque désormais non pas
des quotas mais une quote part
de votre côté monsieur le ministre vous
avez plaidé pour un mécanisme de
répartition solidaire de ceux qui
relèvent du statut de demandeur d'asile
tenant compte des efforts déjà faits par
les pays en matière d'accueil on joue
sur les mots
mais qu'en est il factuellement
bruxelles propose de répartir le
traitement des demandes d'asile entre
les pays européens
ce mécanisme d'urgence qui devrait être
finalisée demain ne s'appliquera qu'aux
étrangers qui ont manifestement besoin
d'une protection internationale
ces personnes seront répartis entre les
28 selon une clef basé sur la
démographie la richesse les efforts
précédents etc
ainsi l'allemagne de bras par exemple en
accueillir 18,42 % la france 14,17 %
soit en se basant sur les chiffres de
2014 un surplus entre guillemets de 26
mille demandeurs d'asile dans l'hexagone
dans l'hexagone et de 7000 régularisés
est-ce donc ce sur plus de 7000
régulariser qui fait sourciller
l'exécutif car en croire le gouvernement
la france a su murray déjà plus que sa
part dans la prise en charge des
migrants notamment ceux relevant de
l'asile pour notre part les élus du
groupe communiste républicain et citoyen
nous nous opposons fermement aux quotas
mais pour une seule et unique raison le
droit d'asile est un principe de valeur
constitutionnelle
il ne serait donc être soumis aux
vicissitudes de nos politiques
d'immigration je le rappelle l'asile
c'est un droit ainsi nous déplorons que
l'examen du texte ait été entre ligne
mais là aussi pollué par le débat sur
l'immigration ont lancé par la
proposition européenne d'instaurer des
quotas de migrants dans l'union dans ce
contexte les termes du débat sont posés
comme étant l'asile est une charge sur
le projet de loi du gouvernement
nous ne pouvions que nous réjouir qu'une
fois qu'une réforme ait lieu pour
améliorer notre droit d'asile à cet
égard nous avons travaillé plusieurs
propositions d'amendements pour
améliorer le texte parmi lesquelles la
suppression des mesures visant à élargir
la procédure accélérée dont le champ
d'application est bien trop large par
rapport à la procédure prioritaire
existantes et qui permettra à l'ofpra de
traiter de manière expéditive
l'essentiel des demandes mais aussi
l'établissement d'un véritable rôle pour
le conseil un entretien l'évaluation de
la vulnérabilité par des professionnels
sociaux et du soin la possibilité pour
les demandeurs de pouvoir bénéficier de
la location financière sans être
contraints d'accepter l'offre
d'hébergement de l'ofii force est de
constater qu'aucune d'entre elles n'a
retenu l'attention de la commission des
lois et du gouvernement pas même celle
visant à revenir sur les dispositions
restrictives restrictives de droit
d'asile
introduite par la commission des lois
bien loin de porter la moindre attention
à nos propositions
la droite sénatoriale s'est en revanche
acharné à rendre le projet de loi du
droit d'asile encore plus dur avec une
accumulation de dispositifs qui ne sont
pas acceptables les délais de traitement
des dossiers ont été ainsi réduit à
trois mois contre 9 dans le projet
initial
où va pas l'effet d'une procédure qui
rend impossible déposé préparer les
dossiers dans le délai requis rendre
impossible droit d'asile en europe
s'insurge à cet égard stéphane campana
le bâtonnier du barreau de la seine
saint denis la suppression de l'accès au
marché du travail pour ceux dont la
sphère est en cours d'examen depuis plus
de neuf ans neuf mois les entretiens ont
été vidés de leur sens en main en
maintenant le droit pour le tiers
accompagnant de se taire et en
instaurant la vidéoconférence pour les
entretiens conduits par le froid pour
déshumaniser davantage la procédure mais
pis encore les mesures les plus dures
vise les personnes déboutées de leur
demande d'asile
avec l'introduction dans le projet de
loi de l'accélération de la procédure
d'éloignement puisque la décision
définitive de rejet prononcé par l'ofpra
le cas échéant par la cndh vaudra
obligation de quitter le territoire
français et interdiction de solliciter
un titre un titre de séjour sur un autre
fondement tel sa situation familiale ou
médicales s'agissant pour le président
de la commission des lois monsieur bah
de lutte et je le cite contre le
détournement massif des procédures de
droit d'asile
à des fins d'immigration illégale
l'assignation à résidence de débouter
dans des centres dédiés en vue de
préparer leur éloignement ce qui confine
selon nous un véritable enfermement
administratif la restriction de l'accès
à l'hébergement d'urgence pour ces
personnes et enfin le traitement le
transfert du contentieux des décisions
de refus d'entrer sur le territoire au
titre de la ville pris sur avis conforme
de l'ofpra à la cnd a plutôt qu'au juge
administratif de droit commun autant de
mesures qui vont dans le sens d'une
surenchère sécuritaire et démagogue
c'est donc devenu un des leitmotiv de la
droite et de l'extrême droite puisqu'un
quart des demandeurs d'asile seulement
voir leur demande aboutir et ben mes
chers amis c'est que les trois-quarts
seraient des fraudeurs rhétorique
trompeuses et infondées les députés sont
avant tout et dans la plupart des cas
des personnes n'ayant pas eu la chance
d'être pleinement entendus
nous le disons avec force ces
dispositifs ne doivent pas trouver leur
place dans notre législation
le droit d'asile mérite mieux que cela
nous ne devons pas en rabattre sur les
moyens pour défendre cette composante
intrinsèque des valeurs de notre
république pour toutes ces raisons nous
voterons contre cette version du projet
de loi tel qu'issu des débats
sénatoriaux j'assume présidente
voilà vous avez donc pu suivre les
explications de vote autour de la
réforme du droit d'asile une réforme
adoptée par le parlement en juillet
dernier un débat sera organisé justement
au parlement sur cette question des
réfugiés
mercredi 16 septembre vous pouvez revoir
bien sûr ce programme sur notre site
internet publicsenat.fr
bon